[Music]
there have been a lot of really great
talks about like cutting edge technology
and like beautiful elegant technical
solutions just to be clear this is not
one of them this talk is about the
darkness those inside technology um even
before I worked for USGS I was always at
one of those engineers that was just
really attracted to like old complicated
legacy technology so prior to us yes I
ran my own moderately successful data
consulting company that focused mainly
on infrastructure it did some work for
the city of New York I did some work for
the major publishing houses I did some
work for the UN and so I sort of became
the person that got called when a
database was in trouble and they didn't
know what to do or how to fix it and
generally these engagements started
something like this we're having
performance issues can you look at our
database and tell us what to do about it
and I would usually respond to this bike
yeah sure can you start off by sending
me kind of like what your data models
are so maybe some sort of visualization
maybe a Visio let's see what this looks
like and usually what I get back when I
make that request is something that
looks like this so what is your first
response to this image like how many of
you are just like oh my god kill it with
fire kill with fire right now and how
many are like this is totally normal I
have a database that looks just like
this at home alright excellent this is
the right crowd so when most people
react to that kind of image they're
reacting to them like the size of it the
number of tables and the problem with
these kind of databases is not really
the number of tables databases can run
very effectively and efficiently with
hundreds of tables or even thousands of
tables it's why you have so many tables
so essentially what I want to talk to
you guys about today is the idea of
technical debt in databases we tend to
think of technical debt as being
something that's specific to application
code but that's not because it doesn't
exist in databases that's just because
technical debt is a product of change
and we change our application code much
more often than we change our database
schemas our data models or our
infrastructure probably the best
explanation of technical
that I ever received was from this
online group called legacy code rocks
which is full of engineers just like me
that are like gimme gimme gimme when it
comes to legacy code and they explain it
this way that when ever you launched a
new feature it's like you've had a house
party and whenever you do refractory
it's like you're cleaning up after the
house party now you can have a house
party and not clean up the next day and
it's not the end of the world but the
more parties you have in your house
before you've cleaned up the worst
condition your house is going to be at
the end of the week so that's the way I
like to think about technical debt in
general but another useful distinction
is to kind of really clearly define the
difference between legacy itself and
technical debt because there is some
overlap especially in the amount of
money that they cost organizations
throughout the lifecycle of the
organization but there are actually two
different things so for example with
legacy code what you see is really clear
and concise and consistent design
patterns that simply do not match the
current fashion for resource
optimization so what I mean by that is
if you take something like a client
should your client be a fat client or
should it be a skinny client throughout
like the history of computer science the
best practice is and the answer that
question has changed over time and
generally what has caused it to change
has been more economics rather than
technical best practice storage becomes
cheaper than it once was personal
computers become cheaper and more
feasible than they once were the
internet gets faster these things cause
those best practices to shift in one way
or the other so with legacy code you
have essentially the design patterns of
another era still trying to run when you
can optimize a system much more
effectively over under a different
pattern with a technical debt you
generally have multiple design patterns
kind of a piling on top of one another
you have like partial migrations so you
end up with a lot of like what what am I
looking at sort of moments where you
can't really tell exactly what the
intention was behind the way the
technology is structure another big
difference between technical debt and
legacy is the effect that the underlying
software and hardware and upgrades has
performance with most legacy
environments when you upgrade the
hardware you upgrade the software for
example the OS you see a boost in
performance with technical debt your
your performance is a problem with the
actual efficiency of the code and the
environment itself so you don't see the
boost and performance from doing those
kind of upgrades that you would expect
and most of the time with databases when
I come into a project the first thing
that they have tried is upgraded the
version of the database to make it run
faster and then they're very
disappointed that they have not seen it
running significantly faster because
they upgraded to a new version the last
thing that's important to kind of
understand the difference between
technical debt and legacy is that in
both of these situations it's very
difficult to bring new engineers into
the team but it's difficult for
different reasons with legacy you're
dealing with a skills gap you may be
dealing with a COBOL mainframe and your
new grads are not coming out of school
knowing how to do COBOL that's a problem
with technical debt you're dealing with
candidates that have the skillset and
the expertise on the infrastructure that
you're running but they simply cannot
understand how the infrastructure could
figure out how the data models work we
had a project two years ago where they
one of the things they wanted to do was
migrate from Oracle advanced replication
to Golden Gate Oracle was deprecating
advanced replication so they called up
Oracle an article Oracle's like no
problem we'll send out one of our
consultants this guy is a DBA he's an
expert in Oracle it took him over a year
to go through all of their data models
and make sense of what their data
warehouses were doing and how everything
interacted and come up with a plan of
how they can migrate their data so when
you're a situation of technical debt you
have the most brilliant experts in the
world and it's still going to take them
a really long time to onboard onto your
system so one of the important things
about technical debt is if you do not
have a way to measure your technical
debt you will always procrastinate and
put off paying it down to another day
and then it will just get worse over
time but measuring tech
okay I have a slide it doesn't like to
show alright anyway moving on I'm
measuring technical debt is actually a
legitimately difficult problem there's a
hilarious cartoon on this slide that you
would be laughing at now you could see
it but you're just gonna have to wait
until I put the slides on speaker deck
now to see the hilarious cartoon one of
my favorite ways of measuring technical
debt is to track the time between when
you start a feature and when this
feature is deployed to production and
look at how much of that time is
actually spent doing regression testing
doing bug fixes and then look at how
that time increases or decreases over
time and then when as you're seeing
increases now you know like okay we've
got the technical debt problem here we
maybe need to come in and clean our
house a little bit there are some other
ways of measuring tactical debt you can
look at the increase in operation costs
you can use static code analysis tools
some people like to do it test coverage
but most of these things focus on
application code they're not really
suitable for looking at technical debt
in the database because we don't really
talk about technical debt in the
database and one of the main reasons why
we don't talk about technical debt in
the database is because most businesses
don't make it past 10 years they either
go out of business they get acquired or
they merge with another company and when
they do something like that when they
have that kind of life-changing event in
the company generally their data and
their databases do not stay the same
somebody's databases get shut down
somebody's databases get migrated over
to a different system the other reason
why we don't generally talk about
technical debt in the database is that
we have kind of a responsibility gap
between the various people who touch our
data infrastructure and what they're
worth what their roles are so we've been
talking a lot in this conference about
the gap between the analyst the data
scientist and the data engineer and who
has responsibilities where and after you
if you were in this room for the talk
right before lunch
there was actually a whole conversation
about can we move those responsibilities
over so that the analysts are taking on
more
of some of the engineering
responsibilities and what are the pros
and cons of doing that but they're even
within the engineering community there
are little silos where we have
responsibilities gaps so how many of you
work for a company where you have DBAs
all right cool
how many you feel like you can explain
the difference between a data engineer
and a DBA we have I think two hands go
up and one of the things that I did when
I was starting to work on this talk is I
actually just asked a whole bunch of
engineering friends I was like what how
would you define the difference between
a DBA and a data engineer and I got a
whole set of really really interesting
somewhat bizarre answers about what the
difference between those two things are
there are some people that think that
data engineer is simply a synonym it is
the new buzzword for DBA and there are
people who think that data engineer is
like an architect who's doing the whole
landscape well as DB is just focused on
one particular type of database but not
being clear about what these roles
actually are and which ones you need
mean that you have question about whose
responsibility is it to clean up the
technical debt in the first place who
optimizes the queries who normalizes the
database who does backups and software
upgrades like how do we determine where
these tasks are so let's go back to this
and let's zoom in a little bit and
simplify this little alright okay this
is the thing now okay so I'm gonna hope
the rest of these slides work because
otherwise it's gonna be very interesting
talk we're gonna look at elements of
this database specifically and why there
are components of technical debt and why
they're problems
so okay good we have a working slide the
first thing the first thing that we want
to look at here is that we have column
and table names that are not
particularly intuitive I don't I don't
know does anybody have any guesses about
what those those those names actually
stand for no I mean it's hard one of the
just to be clear like I made this stuff
up because I find that clients get
really persnickety when you start like
broad
testing their data models on like live
talks but this is actually indicative of
like thing the things that I see in the
wild table names that are based on these
really bizarre naming conventions where
it's hard to actually understand what
you're looking at and sometimes the
rationale behind the naming convention
changes but the naming convention itself
does not change so for example I had one
project where they decided to name all
of their databases after the data center
that it was in and then they shut down
one of their data about it at data
centers and moved it to another data
center and did not change the naming
convention at all so I just had to
remember these random facts about the
history of their company in order to
figure out what I was looking at when I
was looking at a database so what else
is going on this database we have
something that looks like a primary key
that is actually a social security
number so we have personal identifying
information as a primary key and this is
one of the big things that you see first
on a database with lots of technical
debt is improper privacy and security
handling so we actually had a database
where we had that problem and they were
using social security numbers as part of
it keys and first of all I actually
think that is illegal
so the fad product there's that problem
but beyond the legality of using social
security numbers as an ID we wanted to
give them a significantly powerful
performance testing environment and they
had about four terabytes of data in this
database but it was an also an Oracle
database and one of the neat things that
Oracle does is they will optimize
queries not just they will authorize
things not just by the size of data but
also the distribution of data so you
want to make sure that you're not just
dumping 4 terabytes of nonsense into
your test database but 4 terabytes of
nonsense that actually accurately
reflects the structure of the production
data and Oracle has tools that will help
you do that but it's very hard to use
them when you have your primary keys or
social security numbers and you can't
put that in your test database and all
of that some other things that people
that fit in this category is they give
temporary roles that create temporary
user roles because they have application
developers that don't exactly know what
they need permissions to so they just
give it a temporary role that has too
much too much as access to money issue
too many permissions and then never get
rid of it so it's just sitting in the
database waiting for an attacker to find
it they may not be timely and upgrading
their hashing algorithms just in my
professional career we've gone from yeah
plaintext is fine
just you know make sure your database is
secure no one will ever find those
passwords to encrypt it but don't
encrypt it with md5 too now don't
encrypt it with sha-1 either like these
kind of migrations are things that
people sometimes put off far too long so
you'll see that in databases that have
lots of technical debt as well the last
thing is that when people get started
with building a particular architecture
particularly startups they don't want to
necessarily invest in all of the
large-scale cutting-edge tools so they
think they go for a wolf or right now
we're gonna do our message queue
functionality in the database we know
we're not supposed to but we don't want
to set up like a rabid mq and a cluster
and all of that well just do it in the
database and that's fine until they have
grown to the point and they've matured
as an organization where they actually
now do need that architecture and
they've never migrated off of it so
let's see what else we noticed in this
diagram that we actually have a lot of
views we have some data tables that are
in the lighter colors and a lot of views
that are in the darker colors and
database views are kind of fun things
that can be super useful but they can
also hide a lot of dysfunctionality
within the database so the ways they're
useful is that if you are regularly
joining multiple tables of you is super
super useful for that it's essentially a
stored query it makes it much nicer and
neater and easier to query the database
if you're doing they're particularly
useful if you have a table and you want
give a little bit more access control
and subset the data so only certain
users can access only certain parts of
the table you can do them for routine
data calculations like sums or a
geocoding and they're really useful when
you're doing feature flagging or you
want to gradually roll something out
across multiple applications you kind of
create views for each application and
you change the views one at a time and
so the underlying functionality of the
other applications is not affected but
on the other side of things
views can help reinforce developer silos
I've definitely seen engineering
organizations where they get into the
pattern of I have my views and you have
your views and now I don't have to talk
to you about our schema or about what
day that we need or about anything like
that because we will just have our
separate views and so that can create a
lot of problems it hides complexity and
it can push application logic into the
database which I'll get into more detail
a little bit later on but generally
cause this is a whole bunch of different
problems and one of the things that
advocates the views will generate and
say about them is that you're not
duplicating the data you're not
restoring the data so they're small and
they're light they're super easy it's
true they're small but they're not
inconsequential and if you have hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of views it
starts to add up over time and just
increase the size of your database
another thing we have in this database
is we have DB links to other databases
so those of you who are not familiar
with the magic of DV links it
essentially allows you to do a join
across databases by query this table and
it accesses another database and pulls
data from that that table as well and
returns both I mean obviously now you're
dealing with your response time has both
your query time and also your network
speed bundled into it you're also
dealing with issues of directionality
you've now linked these two databases in
these two tables together and you'll get
different performance depending on which
table you query it complicates security
in a number of different ways
you have to make sure that your user
permissions are in sync otherwise you
are essentially giving somebody access
to another database who maybe should not
have access to that database and it sort
of begs the question of why was the data
separated into two databases in the
first place sometimes it's necessary
sometimes you legitimately do not own
the other data set but it creates a lot
of like interesting complications when
you're looking at performance of an old
database
another thing that's sometimes in a
similar vein is the concept of stored
procedures sometimes called trigger
functions depending on which variant of
database you prefer they are essentially
scripts that are inserted into the
database and run on the database itself
advocates of stored procedures will very
quickly tell you that the code runs much
faster in the database than it would
ever run in the application which is
100% true but it you're pulling an
application logic and putting it in a
place where your application developers
cannot see it right
so there's behavior going on behind the
scenes that is hidden from most of your
engineers and one of the things that I
find is pretty common when people are
you heavily using storage procedures is
they're also not putting them into
version control so they're taking the
the attitude that well we're backing up
the database and the database backup
will have the stored procedure in it so
we don't really need to put this in
version control and that sounds great
until you have an incident like we had a
year ago where someone accidentally
wiped the database and none of their
backups worked and we had people digging
through emails from like three years
looking for the stored procedures that
we're supposed to be installed on this
database it just creates like a whole
bunch of chaos when it goes really
really wrong because the stored
procedures themselves tend to be hidden
from the eyes of your engineering team
it can be harder to trace or predict the
impact of changes to the database when
you use them and the last thing I want
to point out in this mythical database
of ours is that we have some blob
column types for those of you who don't
remember or unfamiliar with the term
blob stands for binary large object
they're usually in
audio sometimes executables in the
database essentially things that are not
data and not queryable generally um they
were became popular when storage became
cheap particularly in about the 90s when
network connections were relatively snow
slow because you could just like put say
for example the user's picture or the
avatar in the database with their
profile and then then away you go you
don't have to worry about making another
query but nowadays connection speeds are
much much faster and so we prefer to
take this like giant chunk of space and
not store it in the database but put it
in an object store like s3 or something
like that so when you find it anyways
like this what do you do like how do you
approach these kind of problems in in
the database do you start by auditing
the queries do you migrate the whole
thing to a no sequel solution do you
rewrite and simplify the applications
that are using the database or do you
just light the thing on fire and go home
and just like abandon all hope what do
you guys think like how many you would
Auto the queries was your first down I'm
crap who would migrate to no sequel or
something fancy okay uh who would
rewrite and simplify the applications
using these database and who would like
the whole thing on fire and go home
there are far too many hands yeah so the
approach that I use is that they didn't
get to this place all in one day so
they're not gonna get out of it all in
one day either and we we advocate a
strategy of incremental improvement and
the first thing that I like to look at
when we're troubleshooting a database
like this or actually the non-technical
aspects of it going back to this idea of
the responsibility gap do we have DBS in
this organization do we have data
engineers what other kinds of engineers
do we have do we have a traditional ops
team or more of an SRE DevOps team like
what are were the players in the the
the whole landscape of this organization
and what are their responsibilities and
how do those responsibilities break down
how many of you would describe yourself
as working for a tech company most of
the hands ok so tech companies are great
because they're full of Engineers and it
makes all engineering decisions way
easier but there are lots and lots and
lots of organizations that do really
important technical work that are
actually not tech companies like
hospitals and schools and the federal
government right and those are
organizations where engineers are not
always the first-class citizens of the
organization which means that they have
leadership who are not technical who are
making technical decisions and just sort
of passing them down the chain of
command
I've had this happen quite a number of
times and actually when I was working at
the UN one of the big things that I did
was liaison ting with the leadership of
my project to explain to them exactly
what the little changes they wanted
really meant from a technical point of
view I find the things that create the
most debt are generally described as
just little changes small features like
just stoop super super simple and they
can appear that way because sometimes
their design assets are really super
small but sometimes you're you're
non-technical leadership doesn't
appreciate exactly what it takes to do
that right and what the value of doing
it right is so when you consider these
things in the project that you're
working on the best way to solve them is
by improving the communication tools
that are available to your team organize
chat like slack can be really helpful
because it allows everybody to see
everybody else and figure out who's who
in the organization and message them
really quickly Automation is actually
remarkably useful when you're dealing
with these quarters sort of situations I
would say that probably about 70 percent
of the time when I come in to fix a
database I spend most of my time fixing
their DevOps pipelines rather than their
database because when you start getting
people to automate things particularly
like the deployment and configure
of database instances now they have to
take all those stored procedures out of
the database and put them in some kind
of configuration file that is stored in
some sort of repository that makes it
visible to other people on the
engineering team so getting them to
start doing more automation can be a big
help here and documentation of course
documentation is always a really useful
thing to have when you're tackling
technical debt are they using ORM if
they are then there's there they can
just comment it like they would normal
code if they're not there are ways of
commenting tables that don't require
that so these are important things to
start to consider the first part is
really about like the non-technical
aspects of what's going on how do we get
here and then once you've gotten that
down I think you have to very clearly
define a goal because when you have a
database that's really struggling it's
generally struggling on a lot of
different fronts at once but you can't
fight a battle on multiple fronts so you
got to pick which one is most important
performance security accuracy these are
all things that might be on the table
you've got to figure out which is the
best place to to make the most gains and
then I would say that you prioritize
based on the worst queries although I
want to qualify what I mean by worst
query it's very easy to look at a
readout like this and just kind of go
well okay this query takes 88 seconds to
return that's pretty awful obviously
that is the worst query and to totally
overlook the fact that that query only
runs 13 times a day whereas the one
directly below it takes about 6 seconds
to return but runs close to 7,000 times
a day so it's very very important to
clearly decide what you mean by worst
query it will vary based on what the
database is doing the queries in
question but it's not always obvious
once you've got that down the next thing
to do is to sort of try to minimize the
vectors and what I mean by that is when
you make a change to your database
what are the ripple effects and how can
we can
trol and minimize the ripple effects
with that change so one thing might be
to migrate application logic out of the
stored procedures and into the
application maybe that helps another
thing might be to use database views to
kind of gradually roll out changes and
keep certain applications on the old
model while other applications are using
the new model lastly I would say that
anytime you can reduce the overall size
of the database you can dramatically
improve its performance so another thing
that I like to look at is like why are
they storing the data that they're
storing and do they have to still be
storing the data that they're storing
because generally when we're talking
about these kind of databases we're
talking about really old databases
database system running for 20 30
sometimes longer I think the oldest
system I've looked at was built in 1968
so do the math they're like that's a lot
of data are they still storing all the
data they collected in day one and do
they have to be storing all the data
that they collected in day one and if
they don't then getting them on a
reasonable archival strategy like when
they start to archive data on how much
of their current data they can archive
makes a big difference so now you're
probably thinking like okay this is all
nice and and very interesting but I'm
never gonna work for a company or an
organization that has problems like this
because that's not my thing I'm never
gonna have to deal with this why should
I care and the first reason why you
should care is because when a database
is has been online for longer than 10
years it's generally because the data is
super important like these are some of
the examples of systems that I've worked
on there are like critical for national
security people's pensions like just
making sure that money goes where it's
supposed to and the democracy functions
the way we needed to so the kind of
databases that are generally in the most
trouble are also the most valuable ones
and they work fixing them and optimizing
them is incredibly meaningful second
thing you might want to consider is that
like lately I've been going to a lot of
DevOps and sree conferences and there's
been a lot of talk about being on call
and I hear some
of this quite a lot we're like no matter
how much experience are out brilliant
people are they are terrified absolutely
terrified of being on call because they
might get called when everything is on
fire and then they don't know what to do
and like they'll have a massive meltdown
and everyone will know that they're
unqualified to do their job and the
reality of it is that when you've worked
on really really old brittle systems the
quirks and idiosyncrasies of the smooth
modern systems seem less intimidating
then when you have a hey this is just
not my not my day okay cool I don't I
don't know what this says about about my
face but anyway when you work on on
systems that are super old like the the
experience of being a software engineer
in more modern system becomes much less
intimidating because you sort of come to
the darkness and seeing the worst the
technology has to offer and live to tell
the tale about it the last thing that I
will leave you with as to why you should
like explore working on these kind of
old systems it's totally completely
selfish in nature the way we judge
expertise of engineers generally falls
upon their obscure fact quotient and
like their war stories and when you work
it like normal companies that have a
very nice orderly technology you're very
limited in your war story
potin I like definitely working at USD
as it did boost my my higher ability
rather considerably just from the crazy
stories I could tell people during like
software interviews about this one time
where we had a computer that was storing
environmental day environmental
variables in the Windows registry and we
had to first find the computer and then
convince the person who owned the
computer to let us open up the registry
and kind of like futz around with it so
that we could figure out what the
environmental variables we're I mean
like that's a legitimately fun story so
thank you so much for your time I think
we have a little bit
I'm left for questions no questions wait
there is a mic coming don't worry
what's the worst database you ever
worked with I am NOT going to tell you
by name but I will describe it it may
not be fair to say the worst I'm the
most fascinated by it we had a system
that was very old that was running on a
mainframe from the 60s and they had
actually put modern mainframes in front
of it as kind of like a cache so like
because ultimately this whole thing was
backing a web application which was the
most bizarre thing in the world to me
because I was like you got a web app
that and you traced the data flow all
the way down
that's harvesting data from a mainframe
and I was like this is crazy
but they built like this whole elaborate
chain of mainframes to like protect the
mainframe that was like just 50 years
old so I thought that's pretty high up
on my list for sure over there
you've talked about incremental change
have you ever done incremental change
from like a terrible terrible data
source from a database it's like 20
years old into like a modern cloud
equivalent like hosted shininess and
like cement will process through and how
long did it take yeah actually I have I
would not say that it's all the way to
the shiny part yeah because the the the
database I mean thinking of we worked
started working on about a little over
two years ago and so it takes a long
time like this is like probably close to
20 years of incremental decay but I got
to the point with them where I felt very
comfortable with what the engineers were
doing and more to the point I felt like
the senior level leadership was
listening to the engineers and knew who
had the right ideas and who to empower
and so like all that was working very
very well and so I rolled off to go
respond to something else and came back
like six months later and they had they
originally had a database that was just
full of these blobs lay and the blobs
themselves were pretty small but there
were like millions of them and so it had
gotten so bad that they no longer could
back up their databases because that's
how large this database was and so we
looked at it we said you know you need
to like put this on something else like
a file system of some kind like s3 and
at the time that we came in and we told
them that everybody was like zaxon
possible we'll never be able to do that
when I came back seven months later they
were about 20% into that migration and
they done it on their own which made me
really super excited like that we didn't
have to be there like holding their hand
and pushing them we just had to get some
stuff out of the way for them and they
kind of like decided hey let's do this
cool thing and then went on their own
and started doing it I so I had a
question about one of the things that
I've read about that I really like about
you SDS is that it has a lot of advocacy
for open source software so could you
speak a little bit to the interaction
between OSS and
legacy systems and whether you think
that open-source software is a some kind
of solution to the problems that we have
with legacy systems sure so I would say
that it's a it's a good option I prefer
not to think of technical solutions as
open source vs. closed source I prefer
to think of technical solutions as how
well do they fit the technical
requirements that would have and
fortunately many of those things are in
fact open source nowadays but we have
had situations where the I think the the
best product for our need was a closed
source product so for example there was
a static code analysis tool named cast
that I believe this closed source and we
looked at it we're like well be really
cool if we could do this open source but
this is actually like exactly what we
need for this particular use case so I
would say yes in general but I don't
necessarily make that a qualifying
factor when I'm looking at technical
solutions I had a question kind of going
back to one of your answers like the
previous one of the getting senior
leadership buy off and I know that was a
really important part of the USDA's
mission and do you have any advice for
how do you deal with that and in a
private company we're getting senior
leadership to buy off and acknowledge
that you need to migrate to new systems
and really not necessarily say like
embrace the cloud but like get rid of
the Microsoft sequel servers that are
like under people's desks and you know
move away from fixed files from like
Neilson files from the 80s like how do
you get that buy-in so I would say two
things one persistence and to also
understanding your own value like there
are situations where you can lead a
horse to water but you can't make them
drink so if you understand your own
value and always what your options are
in a given situation then that actually
empowers you to I think being more
respectful in your advocacy so I will
say that when I started working at the
UN I one of the things that senior
leadership used to say a lot is they go
well what
the software is done and I would always
respond to that the software is never
done and then I would explain to them
that like software is a living thing and
it has to be upgraded and justed as
needs are adjusted and so you're never
going to get the point where the website
is built the software is done now we can
go focus on other things and it took me
I think probably about a year to get to
the point where that had internalized
and they understood it and they stopped
saying like when this offer is done but
it we did eventually get there with them
[Music]